SO REALLY YOU CAN'T FLY THAT WAY
TO GET OUT OF RUSSIA.
FREDERICK FLIGHT KIN, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
>>> JOINING US IS RETIRED U.S.
ARMY GENERALLY DAVID PETRAEUS,
THE FORMER COMMANDER OF U.S.
CENTRAL COMMAND.
HE'S ALSO THE FORMER DIRECTOR OF
THE CIA.
GENERAL, IT'S GREAT TO HAVE YOU
AND YOUR INSIGHTS HERE THIS
MORNING.
AS SOMEONE WHO IS SO FAMILIAR
WITH WHAT A MOTIVATED INSURGENCY
CAN DO AND THE CHALLENGE THEY
CAN POSE, I WONDER OF YOUR
ASSESSMENT OF THE RUSSIAN
ADV
ADVANCE.
>> FRANKLY, BRIANNA, THIS IS
GOING TERRIBLY FOR VLADIMIR
PUTIN AND HIS FORCES.
THEY DESIGNED A FLAWED CONCEPT.
THEY HAVEN'T WEIGHTED THE MAIN
EFFORT INTO KYIV, THE CAPITAL,
AFTER ALL THE MAIN OBJECTIVE IS
TO TOPPLE THE GOVERNMENT AND
REPLACE PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY WITH
SOMEONE THAT IS PRO-RUSSIAN.
THEY'RE NOT ACHIEVING COMBINED
ARMS EFFECTS OF INFANTRY ARMOR
ARTILLERY.
THEIR LOGISTICS ARE A MESS.
ON TOP OF ALL OF THAT, VLADIMIR
PUTIN'S ACTIONS HAVE UNITED MOST
OF THE WORLD AGAINST HIM WITH
COUNTRIES LIKE GERMANY AND SO
FORTH TAKING ACTIONS THAT NO ONE
WOULD HAVE IMAGINED POSSIBLE
JUST A WEEK AGO.
SO THIS IS -- THIS COULD
ACTUALLY BE WORSE FOR RUSSIA
THAN AFGHANISTAN WAS FOR THE
SOVIET UNION.
IF YOU REFLECT BACK ON THAT,
THEY LEFT IN AN ORDERLY FASHION.
THE REGIME THEY PUT IN PLACE
STAYED IN POWER, IN KABUL, AT
LEAST, FOR ANOTHER TWO YEARS,
AND THEN THE COUNTRY DESCENDED
INTO CIVIL WAR.
I HAVE INVADED A COUNTRY, A
TWO-STAR GENERAL, A DIVISION
COMMANDER OF ABOUT 120 TROOPS OF
THE 101st AIRBORNE DIVISION, ALL
OF OUR ATTACHMENTION, 254
HELICOPTERS.
I CAN'T IMAGINE ATTACKING A
COUNTRY IN WHICHEVER ONE HATES
US AS OPPOSED TO APPLAUDING US.
WE SHOULD REMEMBER IN IRAQ THEY
DID APPLAUD US.
THEY HATED SADDAM HUSSEIN AND
HIS SONS AND HENCHMEN.
THEN THINGS TOOK A DIFFERENT
COURSE FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS.
IN THIS CASE THE ENTIRE COUNTRY
IS UNITED AGAINST THEM.
MANY OF THE ADULTS ARE TAKING UP
AURMS AGAINST THEM.
NOWHERE IS SAFE.
YOU CAN NEVER REALLY REST.
YOU CAN'T REFIT, THEY CAN'T PULL
MAINTENANCE ON THEIR VEHICLES
WITHOUT BEING UNDER THREAT.
ARMOR VEHICLES REQUIRE A LOT OF
MAINTENANCE, A LOT OF FUEL,
REARMING AND THE REST OF IT.
THE RUSSIANS, THEY MAY BRING IN
THE BELARUSIANS.
THERE ARE REPORTS OF CZECHINS
WHO ARE QUITE THUGGISH.
THERE'S A LOT OF COMBAT POWER.
THEY'LL GET FRUSTRATED.
THEY'LL DO ENORMOUS DAMAGE TO
KYIV IN PARTICULAR.
THEY'LL TRY TO TURN OUT THE
LIGHTS.
THEY MAY EVEN STARVE THE CITY IF
THEY HAVE TO.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, THEY
AREN'T REALLY GETTING TO THE
OUTSKIRTS.
IT'S BECAUSE, AGAIN, NONE OF
THEIR LINES OF COMMUNICATION
BEHIND THEM ARE SECURE.
I WOULD BE AT A LOSS AS TO HOW
TO TAKE ON THIS PROBLEM HAVING
FAILED, BECAUSE THE RUSSIANS
FAILED AT THE OUTSET TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE WINDOW OF A DAY
OR TWO WHEN THERE ARE NO REAL
OBSTACLES ON THE ROADS AND SO
FORTH BECAUSE PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY DIDN'T WANT TO -- IT'S
GOING ABYSMALLY FOR VLADIMIR
PUTIN AND HIS FORCES LITERALLY
AT EVERY LEVEL, THE TACTICAL
LEVEL, SWRID AS YOU SEE, THE
OPERATIONAL LEVEL AND CERTAINLY
AT THE STRATEGIC LEVEL AS WELL.
>> WE'VE SEEN HIM TWICE THIS
STARTED THREATEN THE USE OF
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
NOW HE'S GOT HIS NUCLEAR
DETERRENCE FORCES AND THEY'VE
PUT PUT ESSENTIALLY ON ALERT.
THEY ARE A STEP CLOSER TO BEING
ABLE TO LAUNCH A NUCLEAR WEAPON.
DO YOU THINK HE WOULD DO THAT?
>> WELL, I WOULD CERTAINLY HOPE
NOT.
AGAIN, YOU DON'T RIDE ON HOPE.
YOU RIDE ON REALITY.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO, NUMBER ONE,
IS TAKE THAT VERY SERIOUSLY.
NUMBER TWO, WE HAVE TO START
THINKING THROUGH HOW DO WE
PROVIDE RUSSIA AN OUT?
YOU NEVER WANT TO PUT A GUY WHO
HAS NUCLEAR WEAPONS TRULY IN A
CORNER WHERE HE FEELS HE HAS
NOTHING LEFT TO LOSE.
SO AS THE WEIGHT OF THE WORLD IS
COMING DOWN ON HIM, ON HIS
ECONOMY, HIS FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS AND HIS FORCES IN
THE FIELD, AND AGAIN, THE
UKRAINIAN WILL IS SO INCREDIBLE.
TO SEE WHAT THEY'RE DOING, TO
SEE THEIR PRESIDENT, HE WAS A
COMEDIAN WHO PLAYED THE
PRESIDENT ON TV, AND THIS IS THE
ROLE OF A LIFETIME.
HE SHOULD GET AN ACADEMY AWARD
AND MANY OTHER AWARDS FOR WHAT
IT IS HE IS DOING.
HE'S A NATURAL.
TO SEE ALL THIS COME TOGETHER
FOR THE UKRAINIANS WHO HAVE
NOWHERE NEAR THE MASS THAT THE
RUSSIANS CAN BRING TO BEAR, BUT
THEY'RE DEFENDING, DEFENDING
THEIR HOMELAND AND DOING IT WITH
A HOME FIELD ADVANTAGE.
SO WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS START
THINKING ABOUT HOW DOES VLADIMIR
PUTIN GET OUT OF THIS?
WHAT CAN WE DISCUSS WITH
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY THAT CAN BE
PROVIDED IN THESE DIPLOMATIC
NEGOTIATIONS THAT ARE JUST
BEGINNING TODAY, TO PROVIDE
PUTIN SOME WAY OUT, BUT
OBVIOUSLY NOT CAP PIT LADING TO
THE DEMANDS HE HAS PLACED ON
UKRAINE OR ON NATO AND THE EU.
>> DO YOU WORRY -- WE'VE HEARD
SOME PEOPLE SAY HE'S CRAZY.
DO YOU WORRY HE'S UNSTABLE, OR
DO YOU STILL SEE HIM AS THE
CALCULATING PUTIN THAT MANY
PEOPLE ASSUME HE IS?
>> WELL, I THINK IT'S DIFFERENT
THAN THAT.
HE IS CALCULATING, BUT HE IS
CALCULATING IN A BUBBLE OF HIS
OWN MAKING.
WE'VE SEEN THESE SORT OF BIZARRE
SCENES OF HIM SITTING AT ONE END
OF A HUGE ROOM AND ALL OF HIS
MINISTERS, SUBORDINATES ON THE
OTHER SIDE, AND IT'S VERY CLEAR
THAT HE IS NOT, AGAIN, IN THE
WORLD THAT THE REST OF US
INHABIT IN A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
WAYS.
HIS CALCULATIONS ARE THERE, BUT
THEY'RE JUST DIFFERENT.
THEY'RE BASED ON OTHER FACTORS
AND PROBABLY, UNDOUBTEDLY, NOT
JUST INCOMPLETE INFORMATION BUT
INACCURATE INFORMATION.
IMAGINE BEING THE ONE WHO HAS TO
REPORT TO HIM, MR. PRESIDENT,
THIS IS REALLY NOT GOING WELL,
THIS IS A TERRIBLE IDEA THAT YOU
HAD, YOU OUGHT TO GO SIT UNDER A
TREE UNTIL THE THOUGHT PASSES
AND LET US SOLVE THIS.
OBVIOUSLY, THAT'S NOT GOING TO
BE WELL RECEIVED.
THAT'S THE ISSUE THAT YOU HAVE
HERE.
IT IS A VERY, VERY DIFFICULT ONE
FOR THE WORLD WHEN HE STARTS TO
RATTLE THE NUCLEAR SABRE AS HE
HAS.
WE HAVE TO BE VERY CALM ABOUT
THAT WHILE, OBVIOUSLY, PREPARING
FOR THAT POTENTIAL, EVENTUALITY.
AGAIN, WHAT HE'S GOING TO DO IN
UKRAINE AS LITERALLY THEY WILL
LASH OUT.
AGAIN, THEY DO HAVE QUANTITY AND
MASS.
WE'VE SEEN THE COLUMNS OF
VEHICLES LINED UP.
THE QUESTION IS WHETHER THEY CAN
ACTUALLY GET THEM TO THE RIGHT
PLACE GIVEN HOW CLOGGED THE
ROADS WILL BE OVER TIME WITH
WRECKAGE AND DESTROYED VEHICLES
AND SO FORTH AND THE OBSTACLES
THAT THE UKRAINIAN MILITARY HAVE
FINALLY BEEN PUTTING IN,
DROPPING BRIDGES, FOR EXAMPLE,
SOMETHING THEY DIDN'T DO UNTIL
ABOUT DAY THREE OR SO.
SO, AGAIN, I CAN'T OVEREMPHASIZE
HOW DIFFICULT A POSITION HE AND
HIS FORCES ARE IN AND,
THEREFORE, HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
THAT WE TRY TO PROVIDE A WAY
OUT, BUT AGAIN, KEEP IN MIND,
THERE'S STILL ENORMOUS DAMAGE
THAT RUSSIA CAN DO.
THEY HAVE THESE ROCKET-LAUNCHED
MUNITIONS WHICH LITERALLY SUCK
THE OXYGEN OUT OF THE ROOM AND
OUT OF THE LUNGS OF THOSE THAT
ARE IN THAT SPACE.
HE HAS A LOT THAT HE CAN DO.
I FEAR THAT, AGAIN, IN
FRUSTRATION THEY'RE GOING TO DO
A GREAT DEAL OF THAT, JUST, AS I
SAID, TO TURN OFF THE LIGHTS, TO
TURN OFF THE POWER.
WHAT HAS BEEN SURPRISING AGAIN
IS THE INABILITY TO USE THE
TOOLS THAT WE THOUGHT THEY HAD
IN OVERWHELMING NUMBERS, THEIR
AIR FORCE, THEIR CYBER
CAPABILITIES REALLY HAVEN'T BEEN
BROUGHT TO BEAR.
THEY HAVEN'T COMPLETELY GROUNDED
THE UKRAINIAN AIR FORCE.
SO WHAT THEY'VE DONE IS REALLY
UNDERWHELMING, THEY'RE
UNDERPERFORMING.
THERE'S A POTENTIAL THEY COULD
GET THEIR ACT TOGETHER, BUT
THEY'RE STRUNG OUT ON SEVEN
DIFFERENT AXES OF ADVANCE.
THEY ARE PROCEEDING IN THE
SOUTH.
THAT HAS TO BE A WORRY FOR THE
UKRAINIANS BECAUSE THAT
LITERALLY CAN LEAD ALL THE WAY
UP TO THE SOUTHERN PART OF KYIV,
AND THEN YOU COULD SURROUND THE
CAPITAL BECAUSE YOU'RE ON THE
NORTH, SORT OF STARTING ON THE
NORTHWEST AND THEY MIGHT COME IN
FROM THE EAST, BUT THAT'S GOING
TO TAKE QUITE A BIT.
OF COURSE, THAT UNIT THAT IS
COMING FROM THE SOUTH HAS VERY
EXPOSED LINES OF COMMUNICATION.
AGAIN, I JUST CAN'T IMAGINE
INVADING LIKE THIS AS, AGAIN, I
WAS PRIVILEGED TO DO AS THE HEAD
OF THE 101st AIRBORNE DIVISION
AND WE SEND OUR TANKERS BACK AND
THEY GET INTERDICTED AND YOU
GRIND TO A HALT.
A VERY TOU